what am I gonna make no idea
[Music]
I'm Kayla I'm a lifestyle writer at
BuzzFeed and I tried to be a cook today
I have some food experience I know how
to make general stuff I think I can get
away with making food that tastes and
looks good
my name is Vaughn I am a tasty producer
I grew up working in a barbecue
restaurant in North Carolina I have
lived in France and I've lived in
Thailand I've got kind of a slight
background in pastry I didn't really
know Caleb before this all started but
when I met her I was like wow who is
this beautiful angel that I have to go
against and hopefully crush her soul I'm
nervous I'm but I'm ready let's do it
let's do it preferable that we have more
money 50 can we bargain he says no I
don't know anything about being hungover
so this is gonna be tough are you
kidding
I saw your Instagram story from last
week but when I heard that the challenge
was hangover food I was like yes because
it first off it has to be like greasy
and probably not healthy for you at
least it wasn't something like make a
nice dinner for someone I'd be like oh I
think it can happen I'm confident that I
have some skills in hangover food that I
had the potential to kick your ass okay
well I mean I've been around that block
a couple times so you ain't no hollaback
girl Wow looks like there's a lot of
good stuff in here I feel a little
better now
let's do this alright ready get on I'm
gonna go in iced uh I don't want to make
pasta so I walk in and the first thing I
see is the bread it's like right in the
front of the store and I'm like yes cuz
in the back of mine I said if they have
stuff for grilled cheese that's the
perfect hangover food we can't we've got
perfect like greasy bacon some tomatoes
in there would be good I was thinking
about all the things that like I could
have been missing for something as
simple as a grilled cheese and I was
like sting butter key to a delicious
grilled cheese I knew I was under budget
so I had a little bit of extra money to
spend and I was like what else would
someone have when they're hungover
hair of the dog get some beer I don't
know it's like girl cheese is like
enough to win but it is an easy food
that people would make if they were
hungover I like to dump everything on
the counter and the guy reads it up and
it's $25 a perfect time under budget
five dollars I'm gonna take that five
dollars and celebrate later when I win
go get him tiger
Thanks ten minutes starting I was
thinking fried food greasy food when I'm
hungover I want a meal I don't want just
like dainty finger sandwiches I
initially grab bacon because bacon is
amazing on anything I could literally
[ __ ] on a stick and cover it with bacon
and the crowds gonna go wild
I'm gonna get some eggs man I stumble
across cha mein noodles and find water
chestnuts I find baby corn I find poison
sauce I find chili sauce if I can ground
garlic you need something spicy you need
something flavorful to kind of get your
immune system back in order time is
ticking down for an apartment 25 I've
got five dollars left so I gotta go get
a beer we're getting some booze y'all
$29 I'm getting all my stuff prepped and
the only thing running through my mind
is like how am I going to make this food
within 30 minutes I'm ready you're going
down yo see you on the other side are we
dying I do you are once you try my food
it's amazing from food poisoning go okay
hey I need I need some help like we
literally just I don't know how to turn
this thing on literally they're like go
and fauns like oh and I was like why
don't I don't know how to turn something
on as we say in the South bless your
heart
well the on button might be your first
hint I think it was pretty obvious that
I was making a grilled cheese I had very
basic ingredients and they look over and
mom has this like selection of
condiments and like noodles and foreign
jizz and I'm like what the hell is he
making like what in the world could he
be making with that what are you making
over there wouldn't you like to know
[Music]
q thought sizzle amazing you need some
help over there yeah all right come on
show me how to get this bacon a nonstick
it sticks it first because it's like
developing all that fat content and then
it's going to naturally release from the
pan
I can't hear you over here over the
smell of my delicious bacon your
deliciously raw bacon trills true your
sister trash talk right back girl we
were trying to trash talk each other and
she just kept being like oh but I know
you're gonna do great I'm like girl this
is a competition
we're like smack talking to each other
it gets easier dude it gets easier to
talk should've taken a trip to
flavortown it's over here like there
installed in his like dish and squeezing
oranges and like what isn't this like
I'm gonna be here like butter bread
toast
gonna give him something that they won't
forget just like mom used to make
I don't think bond knew what he was
making he just put a bunch of
ingredients in a pot and it looks good
oh you're gonna do that you shouldn't do
that I shouldn't do what whatever you
just put in there you sure you want to
do that yes I'm sure
oh these aren't like spicy delicious
noodles
I am literally making what I call
everything but the kitchen sink chow
mein it's got depth of flavor it's got
acidity it's got your sweetness it's got
your saltiness it's got texture it's got
a fried egg it's got bacon I'm torn if I
want to make like a stacked grilled
cheese I don't know how that would
really work all competitiveness aside I
would say a double-decker grilled cheese
would be bangin go big or go home
again this is a competition if that's
what helps her win and then I plan it as
a win for myself I mean come on you were
hungover wouldn't you want to eat that
tah-dah
[Music]
Oh mom a double-decker grilled cheese
it's wild and all the best ways thank
you I'm very impressed
I'm glad I took the risk and I would
like to say that sunny-side up egg on
top is like perfection I looked at it
earlier and I almost wish I could do
that myself friendship grew out of this
out of darkness let's get people to eat
it oh right so they can tell me that I'm
gonna win and then I better need
something quick easy simple and tasty
when you're hungover so sandwich for me
this was definitely a good attempt and
there was a lot of bread in there to
soak it up but if I want carbs I'm going
for pasta when you're hungover you don't
you're not excited about dining you're
trying to find anything that will make
you not feel bad I definitely go grilled
cheese this spicy Thai thing is pretty
good I'm gonna let that one my favorites
so you got to drastically different
executions this one is everything and
tastes like nothing this is simple and
tastes the best I think I would say my
winner has definitely got to be the
grilled cheese hair of the dog oh my
gosh wait I have to like reach aced
every thing now with the beer
the winner is I scared
[Music]
probably more appropriate hangover day
I am gentlemen I liked the creative
direction you were going in people just
picked mine because they're like 5 G's
abroad but it was deliciously executed
she's in breath I'm actually really
proud myself was really nervous you know
going up against someone who works at
tasty hello that's a big deal so he
wouldn't be there unless he was really
talented and he is I know who I'm
catering my cuisine to now the audience
of a less sophisticated palate let's
just say hello I'm sorry yeah I can't
see you from his shine Afra trophy all
right I'm John